i think i feel feel fear quite strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear
i feel it quite strongly if you want to
learn physics feynman wrote the book
uh just read the damn book it's all
there
what other habits did you cultivate in
your 20s and your 30s that you now see
as being foundational to your success as
a business person
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
life
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one learn to understand people with
warren buffett
what other habits did you cultivate in
your 20s and your 30s that you now see
as being foundational to your success as
a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i
i i really read a lot and and i aspired
to learn everything that i could about
the subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you
or you could be given 10 of the future
earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that you can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height
no anything no no you're gonna you're
gonna
pick the person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful
generous gives other people credit for
what they do
you know and when you look at all of the
qualities that you admire in other
people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
molester like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you should get rid of those and it's
a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities habit number two
act despite fear with elon musk you're
unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something is
crazy and i know a lot of
pretty crazy people you still stand out
uh where does that come from or how do
you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly um but
there are just times when something is
important enough
you believe in it enough that you you do
it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i
i should if people should think well i
feel fear about this
and therefore i shouldn't do it um it's
normal to be
to feel fear like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong
if you didn't feel fear um
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway
yeah you know actually something that
can be helpful is fatalism
uh to some degree um if you just if just
accept the probabilities
um then that diminishes fear
uh so um starting spacex i thought the
odds of success were less than 10
um and i just accepted that actually
probably
i would just lose lose everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe some other company
could pick up the baton and move
and keep moving it forward so that we
still do some good um
yeah same with tesla i thought the odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low habit number three be
resourceful with jeff bezos
my grandparents would take me every
summer
starting at age four every summer
kind of to give her a break really um
for the whole summer
so i'd be with my grandparents and on
their ranch in catoola texas which is
halfway between san antonio and laredo
we lived in houston and uh so we would
make the five-hour drive out to catoola
they'd drop me off
spend a couple days there then they'd go
back to houston i'd spend the summer
and i went every day the ranch with my
grandfather
to help now a four-year-old boy
on a ranch in south texas is not a lot
of help
but i didn't know that i thought i was
helping and
and then as i by the time i was 16 i
actually was helping
so i have you know i i can
i can suture up a prolapsed cow
i can fix windmills my grandfather was
so resourceful
and that he made his own veterinary
needles
he would take a little piece of wire and
pound it flat with a
with like a oxy acetylene torch and
then drill a little hole through it and
then we would do we did all of our own
veterinary work
some of the cattle even survived and
uh so we had but we had great fun out
there you know
um we built barns and welded things and
he bought a d6 uh caterpillar bulldozer
used like 1955 model year
for five thousand dollars was completely
broken the gears were stripped
and then we spent you know a whole
summer repairing that
the first thing we had to do to repair
it was build a crane to take the gears
out of the transmission
and so you know what i learned from
watching him was just how resourceful he
was he didn't
ever call a repairman he figured it out
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below one of the
biggest things i can say is
differentiate yourself
it's so difficult to be
a small business owner in china it took
me five
months to borrow five hundred dollars
i've always been passionate
some people thought you know it's more
ocd than anything else
habit number four always be learning
with bill gates
if you want to learn computer science
just you know knuth
wrote the book buy it okay uh you know
read it
and do the problems for if you really
think you know this thing
if you want to learn physics feynman
wrote the book uh
just read the damn book it's all there
so that
when we put stuff online we don't have
anything in online physics that's any
better than feynman's book
honest honestly now it's a little easier
to learn
uh you know the guy makes jokes every 20
minutes or at least tries to
uh and he does more demos and things so
learning is a weird social phenomena
and so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the group that does the worst with
online learning are low-income
students because their notion of why am
i learning
their sense of self-confidence the
ability to figure out oh i just got
stuck
because you know two minuses cancel out
and i i never
saw that notation before they just hit
dead ends
all the time that if you're sitting in
your dorm at stanford you know somebody
walks down and
helps you get through it habit number
five stay in touch with new technology
with mark cuban
there's nothing that ai won't impact as
big as the um
so bit having been around a while i saw
the impact of pcs then i saw the impact
of local area networks
then i saw the impact of wide area
networks then i saw the impact of the
internet then i saw the impact of mobile
then i saw the impact of wireless you
know now i'm seeing the impact of
of artificial intelligence and it dwarfs
any of those things and if i don't
understand how to apply it to my
businesses
i mean i remember selling pcs and
software and walking in saying
you don't need to use that pen and paper
on on a you know on a notepad or
a ledger pad now we're going to give you
a spreadsheet and
by the way here's a here's a spreadsheet
that costs 495
dollars and i had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it
which is crazy now when you think about
it but then we said okay now you can
play what if
then we said you can connect these pcs
unless i understood the technology how
was i going to explain it
how was i going to understand it unless
i understand that now how am i going to
invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and
maybe they do maybe they don't and it's
really easy just to have
just to okay so you figure it out that's
just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trading
right i mean if they if you truly
believe ai is going to change everything
how are you going to understand what
people are doing to change everything
unless you at least have a foundational
understanding of it now i'm not going to
build
a million layer neural network and try
to change the world and i'm not going to
show you i'm not going to write a
research paper and saying here's how why
the lottery ticket approach works and
you can build smaller neural networks
with less data and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers
habit number six redefine failure with
sarah blakely
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother
and me to fail so at the dinner table he
would actually ask us what did you fail
at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me and
what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize it at the time
but he was redefining failure for me
and so failure became not about the
outcome but about
not trying and so
you know the fear of failure as we all
know as entrepreneurs
is one of the greatest fears in life
it's one of the things that stops us in
our tracks and keeps us from trying
something
um and so i you know i incorporate that
in my
philosophy at spanx we have we celebrate
failures we talk about them we have oops
meetings where i'll announce the oops
that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach theme
songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important
to try to get the people that you work
with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not safe if i make mistakes
inhabit number seven the last 24 of
every special bonus clip
is don't plan with jack ma
what's up business
yes
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated
but then we do something about it and
when you commit to other people
you increase your chances even further
of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video and then what is your
plan of action around for this week put
it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you
everything you
try to do is already done so when i
figured that out oh what i'm putting out
is what's coming back let me get real
clear
about what it is i'm putting out real
clear
so i read a book about 1989 called seed
of the soul
and in that book gary zhukov talked
about the laws
of karma of the laws of
cause and effect the third law of motion
and in that book he talked about
how intention your intention
is always one
with the law meaning before you even
think about a thing
you have an intention for the thing and
that the
intention is going to determine the
outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen
to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa i changed
everything i did on my show i called in
the producers and i said
from this day forward i will no longer
be speaking to the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do
intentional television
[Music]
if you want seven more rich people
habits check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you work 9 a.m to 9 00 p.m
six days a week and you were given a
hard time because of that
and you backed off a little bit oh